wir haben über 5000 kleine Pakete von
der Deutschen Post abgekauft auf einem
Haufen sieht das ungefähr so aus und ja
das ist extrem viel bezahlt haben wir
22.000 €, was auf jeden Fall eine Stange
Geld ist wir wussten aber auch dass
keine High End Luxusprodukte da drin
sind ich würde mal sagen 30 % kann man
schon eher als Schrott abstempeln womit
man jetzt nicht wirklich was anfangen
kann das sieht dann ungefähr so aus es
kann aber auch coole Sachen drin sein
wie Schuhe Taschen oder irgendwelche
Lockenwickler oder so eigentlich alles
mögliche also spannend war das schon oh
hier haben wir Zalando Frau Heinicke aus
Berlin der Schuhe bestellt